So in this unit and the one before, we looked into
how to model forces and acceleration and how to
come up with a reasonably good numerical
solution of a differential equation. This knowledge
is of course something that you can apply in all
situations in which velocities and forces and
acceleration play a major role. We are going to
apply it in a later unit to design an anti-lock
breaking system. But differential equations can do
much more than just describe vehicles. In the next
unit, we will look at the spread of contagious
diseases for instance by modeling a population as
consisting of susceptible, infectious
and recovered persons.